and tonight's starter is the
right-hander jake woodford making his
first start of this year
second career start so contreras in that
lead-off spot
at woodford deals that's hammered into
left field base hit that's going to roll
all the way to the
wall and contreras around first on his
way to second it's a lead-off double
and that was scorched looked like the
old hanging fastball
just didn't have a lot on in 92 right
over the heart of the play with not a
lot of action
and that's hit on the ground edmond out
in shallow right
gobbles it up and rizzo retired on the
play contreras down to third
baez enters play tonight with an
eight-game hitting streak
swaying and a miss and he struck him out
not the best of sliders from jake
woodford
but that's the pitch that baez will
swing and miss a breaking ball was up in
the zone
now chris bryant he got him
woodford a pair of strikeouts
back-to-back
baez and bryant's picture for the cubs
is indeed
sir alec mills the crafty right-hander
with a wide assortment of offerings
that one drilled the center going back
ortega
back some more near the wall and he
jumps and makes the catch
what a play by ortega he got a great
jump and he didn't care that he was
heading
square towards the wall banged into it
and stole extra bases
holy wow ortega a spectacular catch
robin carlson of two perhaps three bases
great read great break he was playing
deep to begin with but not a single
misstep
along the way and yeah i know there's a
wall there somewhere but i got higher
priorities and that's catch the baseball
oh goldschmidt has been the hottest
cardinal hitter
outside corner ring them up and there's
two away
three fielders to the right a second two
and two of the count mills ready
righty back to work
and a swing and a miss struck him out
mills gets some help out there in center
from rafael ortega
we'll count on jason hayward
and he struck him out on the inside
corner
it's three consecutive strikeouts for
jake woodford
there's a strikeout and that is four in
a row
mills trying to pick up his first hit of
the year
two for 32 in his major league career
first time through the lineup five
strikeouts
for jake woodford it's sharp playing
goldie on a one hopper makes a nice play
to his left
he is undoubtedly in what i've seen the
best
defensive first baseman this year in the
national league he's made
several very tough plays this was not
easy home half of the third bader
woodford and carlson against mills
and a base hit into left field harrison
bader
eight pitch at bad he had a 10 pitch at
bat yesterday
woodford lays down one to rizzo the only
play is tagging the runner that beat
woodford and he's out so he does his job
with the sacrifice
and now it's dylan carlson 3-1 pitch
carl sand base head in the center
here comes bader the throw from ortega
knocked down by rizzo one nothing
cardinals on a base hit
dylan carlson this is just good baseball
here
is bryant and hayward against jake
woodford strikes out for the second time
woodford now with six strikeouts well
the book on baez today is you can get
him out with a hanging slider
bases loaded for the young
and the young a high chopper left side
off the glove of the shortstop baez
everybody's safe and it's two to nothing
st louis
really tough play and a short hop coming
in for baez
the bases remain loaded vader first
pitch
first play at the plane they throw it
away a run will score
it's another error it's a three nothing
lead for st
louis three airs by the cubs in the
inning
two by bayas won by patrick wisdom the
bases remain loaded
3-1 pitch and he walked him
he walks in a run old schmidt over two
bases loaded headed way out in front
is anybody gonna get to the bag the
answer is no and a run will score
this is hard to believe now the
cardinals are scoring
here in the home half of the fourth and
the cubs have the bases loaded
no out here in the top half of the fifth
inning the cardinals up
five to nothing and ian happ will pinch
it
for the pitcher alec mills on the ground
out to short
one there skipped to first dug out by
goldschmidt two there so it comes on the
board but it's a double play
there's dylan carlson rbi single in the
third
carlson deep right stay there
homer dylan carlson
the only question is would it stay fair
it did
four rbis in this game for the cardinal
right fielder
to know the count on paul goldschmidt
and an infield base hit with the bases
loaded in the fourth
and goalie lifts it high in the air out
to right center
back to back back to back home runs
carlson now goldie 8-1
st louis great results in his last two
at-bats
two at bats ago he hit the ball 70 feet
and had an rbi
this time he hits it quite a bit further
into right center field back to back big
flies over on that number 16 for goldie
andrew miller left-handed the first
person he'll face is patrick wisdom
that's drilled left field way back
on and wisdom has gone deep
against his former team patrick with
number 14. that's got to feel great
in a blowout but nevertheless yeah that
was a laser that got out of here in a
hurry
he kind of took a moment to admire it
eight two cardinals eighth inning one
away with a man at third the batter is
chris bryant
bounce towards third sosa
well comes in and brian picks up rbi
number 48
eight to three as we move to the top of
the night the three two pitch
rumble hit to the right side taken there
by tommy edmund and the out
off again two edmond two goldie in the
out
3-2 pitch fly ball to center this will
do it
bader under it has it cardinals are back
at 500.
they're 47 and 47.